this guy started a business selling hot
dogs and he was given One Wish from a
genie of what competitive Advantage he
would be able to have the first thought
he had was like maybe I'll make my hot
dogs cheaper the genie shook his head
and was like no he's like hm what if I
made my hot dogs taste better and the
genie said no don't waste your wish on
that maybe I'll just make mine the
fastest cooking so I can serve the hot
dogs faster J said that's not what you
want to waste your wish on the genie
looked at him holding the hot dogs in
buns in hand and said it's not about the
hot dogs if you want to build an amazing
business you want to put your hot dog
stand on the best corner in front of a
starving crowd because if your hot dog
stand is on the corner it doesn't matter
how cheap they are how good they taste
how fast they cook the moment that
hungry crowd walks out and sees your hot
dog stand you're going to sell it every
time yeah